there is something very
like you and i in this conversation
there's a few people listening to this
all of us are in a kind of
single mind together
there's some small aspect of that
and
or maybe a big aspect
about us humans
so certainly in the space of ideas we
kind of um
meld together
for time at least in a conversation
and kind of play with that idea and then
we're clearly all thinking like if i say
pink elephant
there's going to be a few people that
are now visualizing a pink elephant
we're all thinking about that pink
elephant together
we're all in the room together thinking
about this pink outfit and we're like
rotating it
um like you know in our minds together
what is that
that pink is that
is there an different instantiation of
that pink elephant in everybody's mind
or is it the same elephant and we have
the same mind exploring that elephant
now if we in our mind start petting that
elephant like touching it that
experience that we're now like thinking
what that would feel like
what's that is that all of us
experiencing that together or is that
separate so like there's some aspect of
the togetherness that almost seems
fundamental to civilization to society
hopefully that's not too strong but to
like some of the
fundamental properties of the human mind
it feels like the social aspect is
really important
we call it social because we think of us
as individual minds interacting but if
we're just like one collective mind
with like fingertips they're like
touching each other as it's trying to
explore the elephant
but that could be just in the realm of
ideas and intelligence and not in the
realm of consciousness and it's
interesting to see maybe it is in the
realm of consciousness yeah so
it's obviously certainly true in some
sense
that there are these phenomena that
you're talking about of
collective consciousness in some sense i
suppose the question is
how
ontologically serious do we want to be
about those things by which i mean
are they just a construction of out of
our minds and the fact that we interact
in the standard standardly
scientifically accepted ways or is as
someone like rupert sheldrake would
think that there is some
metaphysical reality there are some
fields beyond the scientifically
understood ones that are somehow
communicating this um
i mean i think that i mean the view i
was describing was that this element
we're supposed to have in common is
is some sort of
pure impersonal consciousness
you